guys were kind of a big inspiration
because over the pandemic I I just
hearing you guys laugh really lit me up
oh that's nice because it's like belly
laughs were needed and um it felt really
good and um I you screwing around with
people on this podcast is kind of like
what I want to do except I'm a musician
so it's a little bit different no but
it's the same idea there's such a we
talk about this a lot on the show but
I've been fascinated all my life with
the fact that I have a
um natural uh you know bent towards
comedy but I'm always The Grass Is
Always Greener I'm always peering over
into the music yard I see that and
thinking man that's so cool that's the
cool place to be I'm over here with the
Laughing clowns
well sorry not you guys
don't think of you as comedians at all
oh well um